so what do you want you don't know who
the [ __ ] I am
what are you doing that got away from me
my name is max Caulfield I'm 18 years
old
years ago my family moved away and I
left behind my childhood after five
years I'm back in my hometown Arcadia
Bay Oregon now I'm studying photography
at Blackwell Academy my new home in the
end it's still high school which kind of
sucks the news Chloe
oh [ __ ] home
but dance or take my picture with your
new camera come on rock out girl then
something happened something that
changed my life forever max what's going
on where am I
there's something else I have to tell
you holy [ __ ]
talk to me max I discovered I could
reverse time max start from the
beginning
Chloe
in the bathroom today you set off the
alarm Ujala saved my life then I
realized I had a choice Hey okay and the
power to change everything
[Applause]
the hell
come on slowpoke if I see you here again
you'll learn all about real trouble
so what would you do now
[Music]